In the US, President Donald Trump...
...says he has "suspicions" about the crash of a Ukrainian airliner outside Tehran...
...as US media reports it had been mistakenly shot down by Iran.
In Iran, the head of the Revolutionary Guard's Aerospace Force Amir Ali Hajiradeh,...
...said Iran's missile attacks on US targets in Iraq did not aim to kill American soldiers...
...but were a "lesson" to get US troops to withdraw from the region.
In the UK, British lawmakers backed British Prime Minister Boris Johnson's Brexit deal,...
...just three weeks before the 31st January deadline.
Riot police in France clashed with demonstrators in Paris...
...as they marched against changes to state pensions.
Finally from Mexico, Popocatepetl volcano exhales a thick cloud of smoke...
...that reached three kilometers high after eruption.